hello and welcome to this video
pail zine okay yeah blackest angling
form a closed catalan with the bishop on
d6 g5 is often played now this is a line
where I'm wider is only marginally
better it's not not much
I'm ready yeahi for him
my gonna form I can also take on d5
which is a bit uncommon probably nobody
for you know form seems fun yester
basically has to trade Queens
no no it should be comfortable night
yeah 93 is weird and now we have this is
not so clear if you want to go to a 5 or
if you want to go to to these six I'm
going to go to a five this is often the
better square in fact because you attack
be seven and you cannot ever move the
b-pawn almost never move the b-pawn
because of the constant threat against
c6
in addition
yeah I know I don't Bishop g4 is just
not a good move I think I mean maybe yes
doesn't have anything better of it it is
just going to get kick - the whole time
SMO here he wants to play Bishop age
five and be sure to have seven and yeah
I probably just double them
maybe he wants to play c5 is that
something no I can just like c5 actually
whoopsie one and basically wind upon
okay now King looking to is seven
I don't quite don't quite see a way
forward this mouth is my problem it
looks it looks nice but I don't quite
see how to how to make any headway
probably this is one of the few ways to
get a little something going what kind
of a time what is he doing here
Bishop seven looks completely forced
my dears King up to a four and then H 45
and so on
it cannot play rock the aid because of
night takes B seven at the end that's
the benefit of the snide
okay
but okay c5 i Goti five where the issue
is is the time
[Music]
yeah I can go to the five now
flex flex time management is quite
irritating and he spends quite a bit of
time and totally for smooth maybe I
should have gone to e5 it looks far more
natural
okay now is there a way to you know know
the five six is too early what I mean to
have seconds 96 is a threat double
attacking basically
and now he just does not stop me from
promoting
I can also win the h-bomb here was kind
of tough I mean it was it was a very
nice position but it was difficult to
make progress so yeah this is yeah 95 is
interesting anyway you cannot you can go
to the six of course but this is often
the more annoying square and now I got
this long term pressure but it was
difficult to make anything concrete them
I mean this little thing is okay I'm
giving up a five but then the night
doesn't go them now running up here and
now e5 maybe that is wrong timing but I
wanted to yeah I wanted to do stuff I
had very little time left and probably
this is not best yeah he can go Bishop
d5 I suspected that you should put
something on d5 yeah the worst is over
fam so II five was wrongly timed ninety
seven however this is this is still a
fair amount of pressure for me and I
should probably go to e5 you know this
is probably more dangerous and then g5 +
f6 decide yes g5
hmm f6 is a nice move I didn't see this
yeah this is made so he has to go back
and then taking and this is a great
opera sim so this is better than H form
but I'm still having a nice position
over here I have six wins okay there's
very nice very nice okay now I didn't
spot that I just saw that this is a good
ending and then then I wait for it yeah
I don't think you kind of waters really
see five wasn't the toughest we should
age five that's what the engine wants to
play and sometimes something like that
should probably win the the activity is
just very very very important with the
centralized King and everything is
playing and he's just in a passive
position okay guys thanks for watching